let's just bring us the latest that we
are getting out of Russia the Russian
President Vladimir Putin has issued a
video on the Kremlin website this is his
first statement since an armed Mutiny by
the Wagner mercenary group
congratulating uh sorry this is his
first statement since the coup over the
weekend the attempted coup over the
weekend but he is not referring to it in
this video he is simply congratulating
participants of an industrial Forum not
entirely clear when or where the
statement was recorded he did of course
make a national address to the Russian
people on Saturday condemning the Mutiny
by Wagner nurseries as a stab in the
back and vowing to crush it and he has
not commented publicly on what
subsequent deal was announced on
Saturday which has appeared to Defuse
The Crisis by allowing Wagner fighters
to return to base and their leader
yevgeni pagodian has moved to Belarus so
possible Bloodshed has been averted
there but this is the first time that
we've seen President Putin on camera
a statement coming from the kremlin's
website since this armed Mutiny at the
weekend and he is here not talking about
it but congratulating participants of an
industrial forum